okay let's um sort of uh circle back for
lack of a better term to some of the
stories we've been covering and are kind
of coming to
fortunately natural conclusions now one
is the comedy of errors
of uh the right on social media and
technological incompetence that seems to
plague
so much of the right of course we've
talked about parlor we've talked about
the
mike lindell my pillow platform that
failed miserably
we now have another instance of this and
after months of teasing a revolutionary
new social media platform that was going
to be
on the technological vanguard of free
speech and open communication
donald trump has launched his so-called
platform
it's just an outdated looking blog page
with
erratic and unhinged posts from donald
trump
they actually produced a video
announcing
that i don't i can't even really call it
a platform because it's just a blog
um and this is like a campaign ad
for a blog uh take take a look at this
and sign him and those who supported him
in the senate
of history twitter permanently banning
the commander-in-chief's personal
account
with 88 million followers
so there it is donald trump with a
defiant message
that he will not be silenced um
so what is he posting to this blog it's
basically just tweets
uh here's one about mitt romney where
donald trump wrote so nice to see rhino
mitt romney booed off the stage
at the utah republican state convention
they are among the earliest who have
figured this guy
out a stone cold loser here's another
trump
blog about the 2020 election where
donald trump writes quote
the fraudulent presidential election of
2020 will be from this day forth
known as the big lie
a few days ago here is one about the
so-called audit that's happening now
i know it's may of 2021. you might be
thinking audit what are you talking
about
the big audit that uh he says is going
to really reveal some things in arizona
donald trump writing quote big victory
today in
arizona a highly respected judge
has just ruled that the forensic audit
being done by the arizona state senate
can
and will continue over 100 democrat
lawyers were sent to fight against this
audit
the results will be very interesting for
the usa and the world to see
why are the democrats fighting so hard
to hide the facts
i know why and so does everyone else
so this is basically another grift
there's a big
contribute button at the top of the blog
and
i guess if you want to donate to trump
at this point
i don't know what you're donating to it
seems maybe 2022 candidates that trump
determines are worthy of his support or
of
your money you can do that and one of
the funniest things is that fox news
took the bait hook line and sinker and
they announced
this as a platform publishing an article
called quote trump launches new
communications platform months after
twitter
facebook ban and then the hilarious
subtitle
is the space will allow trump
to post comments images
and videos so basically
um it's a blog it's basically blogspot
or blogger installed on donaldjump.com
the news is trump started a blog
now to be clear considering the caliber
of trump's audience
this as a quote platform probably
suffices but you could really make
something more dynamic in 10 minutes
with like the godaddy site builder or
squarespace or something like that but
this may be what trump has to rely on
uh of course um we learned today that
donald trump's ban from facebook is
being extended but not indefinitely it
was
originally an indefinite ban from
facebook facebook's advisory board we
talked about this earlier announcing
today
that it is no longer indefinite it will
be reviewed again
in about six months but it is going to
go
at least several more months so donald
trump relegated to this now here's my
question for you
um why do you think
that the right is so plagued
with technology issues many of them
hilarious i
completely admit if you go back this is
not new if you go back to the 2008
election
where in a sense it was the first
election where
the online organizing space was really
prominent in a presidential race in 2004
with kerry versus bush
there were newsletters and you were
starting to see but that was very very
early in 2008 obama versus mccain
you really saw a dramatic difference and
i remember being on both of their
newsletters and monitoring both of their
websites
the caliber and effectiveness and and uh
scope and frequency of communication
online from the obama campaign
was just dwarfing what the john mccain
campaign was doing in 2008
and since then we've continued continue
to see this divide
um while the ground game particularly
locally
is often much better for republicans
than for democrats we've seen this
continued
gap favoring democrats on the online
organizing and of course
the parlor fiasco is a more recent
phenomenon
uh the my pillow uh
mike lindell frank speech disaster
is another one um the
so so i don't what do you think it is
is it that um i don't know is it
something about
who are the targets of the communication
and that's why the right is using
antiquated websites
and relying on facebook because they're
trying to reach disproportionately older
people
i don't know what the answer is but i'd
be curious to know your thoughts as to
what
explains what is now almost 15 years
really
of significant and persistent
disadvantage for the right
when it comes to online organizing one
of our sponsors today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
but the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products the link is
underneath this video